plan il ya eu cette polémique regardez
puisqu'au moment de l'annoncé de la
victoire est là vraiment tout le monde a
crié au scandale
on a les conclusions de l'enquêté
attendu delphine ernotte la patronne de
france télévisions a dit j'ai compris
maladif d'affilée un autre on ne va pas
discuter avec ces réclamations at elle
elle a donc sous peu à l'adie l'italie a
gagné on va pas discuter 30 bars est
allé faire gagner mabrouk a dit qu on
est bien reçu
quand même un dans la veine rhône média
heureux si heureux d'être ici
là tout le monde a dit qu'il avait pris
de la cocaïne
c'est vrai que ça a été un truc de fou
alors est-ce que vous avez des
conclusions des enquêtes pas aux oui
alors les âges qui est tombée juste
heuliez toujours dit la dépêche négatif
il n'y a aucune consommation de drogue
de cocaïne sanaa vers une autre et donc
lui il s'est penché ce qu'il a fait en
fait il s'est penché c'est juste c'est
fake news corp sic qui ensuite ont
commencé à affûter sur les réseaux c'est
devenu un truc qui a pris des
proportions franchement complètement
disproportionnée et mais non il n'a pas
mêmes et même le me demande aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on devient on devient des
américains de moralisateur une sorte de
moralisation
on peut pas fait ça si c'était avéré il
paraît qu'il aurait une amende
oui parce que le règlement est très
contrôlée c'est pendant la prestation et
comme c'est hors prestations
ils se sont dit on ne va pas pouvoir le
déjuger d'ailleurs ils sont à changer le
règlement parce que sur le plan de la
morale
si la paix de la drogue c'est
inacceptable mais c'est vrai qu'au
niveau du règlement ce serait passer sa
loge alexandra est ce que vous quand
vous avez appris ça est là bas quand
vous étiez sur place
est ce qu'il ya eu cette rumeur de de
cocaïne pour ce chanteur vous avez vous
avez dit on va faire une réclamation pas
du tout non pas du tout ça s'est passé
très vite juste après donc nous ont
savouré cette deuxième place on était
ensemble et c'est quand on a été à la
conférence de presse finalement qu'on
nous a renseigné sur ce qui s'était
passé
en aucun cas ce que je veux dire on a
gagné une place on est loyal
on prendra pas cette place cette
première place il s'était passé quoi que
ce soit je crois que aujourd'hui ils ont
été plébiscités par le public
c'est ça qui refait et qu'il faut
retenir bravo italien donc nous pour
vous il n'ya pas dire pas alors il fait
on n'en pas de débat non mais avec
sandra oh si c'était vrai je pense que
quand même tout le monde est parti ce
qui gagne et qui est loupée et là vous
êtes quand même rapporter 200 millions
de téléspectateurs vous avez quelqu'un
qui gagne comme ça si vraiment les
filles il avait fait ça en direct à
l'antenne à un véritable scandale cela
change rien à la chance il faudrait
louis complètement honteux mais pas
vraiment ça ça reste une compétition
donc il faut pas il faut pas se droguer
et avoir un avantage par rapport aux
autres il ya des ja de la bière il ya du
vin il ya du champagne s'est très bien
passé il marcha spahis n'est pas fini je
me pose c'est ce qui vient d'arriver
c'était dans un placard là là là on voit
qui se baissent qu'est ce qu'il ya
qu'est ce qui fait qu est ce qui
ramassent écoute vers ce soit 4 sebha
qui tue le ramasse à tulle pussacq tard
après que ton et wasquehal et alors on y
va respirer
la réunion la face tyson tu peux dire
que j'en ai bien son patin côté adrian à
ce travail avec le vinson porte à côté
ouais c'est bizarre alors oui j'ai dû
arrêter choqué et je voudrais bien en
cours bien choquer syriens alors je vais
vous dire il ya une enquête mais elle
épie lé big match et je vais vous le
dirait notre ami italien là vous allez
en prendre une bonne excuse au fond
d'une boîte est il aurait dû être fait
tout de suite et ça madame je vous en
veux vous auriez lui porter réclamation
qui est un test anti drogue tout de
suite et on a attendu qu'il retourne en
italie où jacques santer d'accord un
jour quand il était chez lui
vous avez le test 15 quelles sont les
substances qui ont été recherchées
est-ce qu'on a tous détecté pour un
italien at-elle fait en italie à la
maison monsieur qg moi je ne dis pas
qu'il a pris de la drogue se serait
diffamatoire jeudi que le test il est
bidon
on a une tradition juridique qui puise
ses racines dans les millénaires où ils
jusqu'à preuve du contraire on demande
des preuves et lui ce monsieur le
chanteur il s'est même prêté il a fait
quelque chose qui juridiquement est
complètement faux c'est à dire qu'il
s'est plié à cette volonté de faire un
test volontaire dont déjà ça
donc ce que vous dites est vraiment aux
abords de la mairie de réclusion d'un
point de vue plus concret parce que ils
sont partis de rotterdam dimanche pierre
hier soir ils sont arrivés à l'aéroport
de rome
léonard de vinci et ce matin il s'est
prêté alors moi j'ai vu des études et la
cocaïne et reste dans le sang de 2 à 4
jours donc on est dans les temps je
pense vous pouvez nous le confirmer
alors il faut spécialisé en tout cas
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose qui importe la direction
de l'eurovision c'est justement
responsable de ça ce n'est pas aux
allégations d'aller porter réclamation
oui je dire je vous rappelle que quand
ça sort on vient de sortir finalement de
2h30 l'émission intense
on est là pour ça vous risquez en train
de se passer qui s'est pas passé depuis
30 ans
non on n'est pas là à se dire qu'est ce
qui se passe on veut récupérer la
première place
nous sommes fiers bonjour et zebra
majorité garde à des déviations je reste
un scandale un rythme et je peux te dire
moi ouais mais je comprends et où il se
faire piller away si c'est une merde à
aujourd'hui et ce souvenir là pour
devenir parce que si je pense qu'on
regarde le doigt est pas la lune
la chose magnifique aujourd'hui c'est
que l'italie et lavera sont 1re et 2e
c'est un magnifique second tour
l'union européenne parce qu'ensemble ils
taillent et france on ne doit pas tomber
dans les pièges qui ont changé des
choses aujourd'hui et rassure comme les
citoyens sont appelés à auxerre est fier
attribué à désigner l'europe de demain
mais ensemble on peut vraiment
construire une erreur on est encore là
avec la rigueur et la raison c'est très
important d avoir divisé la france